good evening we start tonight with
breaking news out of henderson where one
person is dead after they were
apparently hit by a car
police working to figure it all out
right near las vegas boulevard and st
rose parkway that is where we find
madison
kimbrough joining us with the very
latest on this breaking news madison
yes brian it's still a very very active
scene take a look behind me where you
can see henderson police
are out now this is what we know so far
shortly after
this is what we know so far shortly
after four henderson police and fire
were called out
to a desert area south of the m resort
for a pedestrian that hit
by a vehicle now unfortunately by that
time they made it the person
died this is what investigators are
saying a man attempted to steal a
victim's car
that man hit the victim with that car
and then ran off on foot
from the area right now police are
searching for that man and have air
units assisting
we don't know the identity of the person
who died we don't know if it's a man or
a woman but currently
there are a lot of police in the area as
they look for the man you can also see
or hear at least there are helicopters
in the sky so it's very active here
but we will bring you the latest on air
and online as soon as we know more
information
so stick here with 8 news now reporting
live in henderson
madison kimbrough 8 news now